Ramadhan we know that Ramadan is
something that is a continuation of the
legacy and the mission of all the
prophets that the crater sent Jesus
fasted Moses fasted Abraham fasted they
were all natural monotheists they only
worshipped the crater not the creation
they all establish prayer which we do
five times a day they all gave in
charity which we do they all visited
Beca Mecca first house of worship built
by Abraham to commemorate the worship of
the one creator and Islam being a way of
life that protects the sanctity of life
that protects your mind and especially
your heart that's what I want to focus
on you know the last and final mission
there said to mankind the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
said there's a morsel of flesh in the
body that if it's sound the whole body
will be sound we have so many toxins
from the pollution from food toxins fake
food you know I've been talking a lot
about fake food the spiritual toxins the
things that we see the things that we
hear they affect our heart our iman our
faith is either going up or down if
you're listening and bobbing your head
in the car during Ramadan if you can
control yourself your Neffs your desires
especially now during this training camp
during Ramadan it's going to be much
easier well law is gonna be much easier
now and that's the whole goal the
mission that after a makan Ramadan you
come out on a batterer Muslim a better
submitter to the Creator a better human
being you've developed yourself
you lose out now what am I gonna say
Khan now is the time if you're bobbing
your head to Lady Gaga googoo 55 cents
to pop Katy Perry
Miley Cyrus you name it this is
affecting your heart this is going to
with this audio pornography and all this
hip-hop bling billing music you got to
cut it out replace it with with the
provider verbatim Lord's got listening
in your car you have in your way when
you're traveling you have so many apps
out there where you can listen to good
positive messages good lectures good
reminders and you'll see that you feel
different admit I mean think about that
you know you might have a moment of that
feel good and you're moving around and
going faster in the car and you like
they put you in a lot of life fantasy
land that's all it does then Dan and
incites these desires and you want to
you know you start thinking of things
you want to go do things and all these
things are mostly bad things you end up
just being hit in a hypnosis state but
as this as we're aware we're cognizant
of the reality that life is a gift and
every moment is is precious when I sat
in an in Santa Fe hostess in La La Vina
and an evangelist Olli happy whatever I
saw them up to whatever service above
the crater swearing by time look all
mankind is bankrupt this is what we have
and we're wasting it the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
the things that people take for granted
is what good health and time so you're
wasting time you're not getting any good
deeds but you're actually having the
melech writing the bad deeds when you're
listening to things that are actually
calling you to the disobedience and to
to things that are not appropriate and
only bring harm upon you so that's why
you you feel this trepidation you
his unease confusion which this creates
another thing I want to touch upon and
I'm done is the social media these tools
many of them can be used for great good
but when we're constantly if you have so
many friends you don't even know would
you accept a stranger came up to say hey
can I just be your friend you don't know
this person is persons befriending you
and now or even you have other people
out there that maybe family met whoever
the case you end up how much time are we
spending looking at other people's
profiles how much time are you spending
checking on Instagram the person that
took that nice shot the perfect picture
perfect shot and now you're judging your
life and you sing oh how happy they are
and how miserable I am you know the
Prophet SAW someone said always look to
those who have less you appreciate what
you have you don't know if that person
right after that picture had the worst
argument with their wife their house is
upside down they took three hours just
to plant that perfect picture whatever
the case don't get caught up and then
let's say just for an example 50 friends
right every day on the newsfeed you're
going through each one you're given one
minute on top of Facebook we're not even
adding snapchat imagine how much time
you're wasting you're gonna be asked
about it and if you would have taken
that time and implemented now especially
during the month alone or my dad into
the Chrome App there shouldn't be a day
that passes that at least you don't read
one page
pick up a good English translation if
you don't even love the Arabic and read
at least one page come on you could do
more one page and instead of the music
the bling-bling the filth that you see
much of on the TV it's not even the
cable just the regular TV I say cut it
out because what are you Steven the
commercials promiscuity saw pornography
that all affects the heart that you want
to protect and that this Dean came to
protect and if it's not sound you will
be affected your mind will be affected
your clarity of thinking will be
affected it's gonna go down and no
wonder mood swings you're gonna be
anxious nervous anxiety you're gonna be
missing out on that piece of contentment
that happiness
we all are susceptible to these toxins
this is a reminder first to myself and
to those listening and we have to be
aware of this how much time are we
putting into looking at the
picture-perfect moments that people are
taking and you're seeing a lot of
inappropriate pictures out there sisters
protect yourself part of being a woman
in hijab is that modesty this also goes
for the brothers with the babyGap
t-shirts and whatnot cut this out same
thing with the sisters she's a shy
intelligent strong woman that was
respected for her mind not exploited for
her body and Muhammad Ali he gave him
great we promote all this modern-day
American hero see what his stance was
and what our Deen how it came to
preserve and protect and now you see
others and now you think you're missing
out you think you're gonna gain some
happiness by showing more because they
are because you become desensitized the
culture is promoting it no no no you're
affirm your muslimah
you're an ambassador you follow the
example of Jesus's mother Miriam alayhi
Salaam and you protect your chastity
your morality your modesty and you have
a great reward promised from the Creator
from Allah for you for that it's a
struggle it is a struggle it's a jihad
to struggle to be upon righteousness
I've hurt you while everyone around you
is calling you to do the opposite don't
do the opposite let us spend our time
wisely what do we take from this throw
out the CDs throw out the music things
that are enticing you not helping you to
suppress the desires they're waking up
the desires and motivating you to the
disobedience is this pleasure of your
Creator Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
replace it with good messages good tones
with good advice with crab and let's
tone it down you use these social media
tools for things that are constructive
that will help to increase the Eman if
you're seeing that it's because it goes
through the eyes to the heart at
penetrates and man it's like a poison it
hurts it hurts brothers it hurts when
you look at an appropriate thing you're
not lowering the gaze and same thing for
the sisters it hurts we have a mission
in this life we have a purpose in this
life and is to plant these seeds of
goodness and to help make the society a
better place help make our lives that we
live an example for others to follow of
goodness not to just sir come to the
cultural norms that many go against the
values that we try to live by and the
ambassadors of this day
you